former Clark County elected official
accused of murder will represent himself
at trial this morning a Clark County
Judge reluctantly allowed Rob tell us to
be his own counsel now tell us as you'll
remember was the County's Public
administrator he is accused of killing
Las Vegas Review-Journal reporter Jeff
gearman who had written several stories
about him Telus is now being held
without bail on these murder charges
before her ruling Judge Michelle Levitt
raised concerns over telus's decision
his desires and his lack of experience
with criminal law
you don't have the experience you've
told me you don't you represented
and I think you're going to prepare
yourself to be ready to go to trial
well tell us trial is scheduled to begin
in November